hey guys I'm out of the country at the
moment but we didn't want to leave you
hanging with no clips so here is someone
on The View saying something most likely
racist bigoted homophobic transphobic or
just generally stupid I do want to push
back a little bit on antifa I mean FBI
director Christopher Ray called them an
extremist group he called them
anarchists and Congressional
I agree they're not working out no one
has found anti we've heard a lot here
we talk Sonny's brought up many times
about the FBI director speaking about
white supremacy being the number one
target he also said that same trusted
source that it's a real thing it's not a
fiction it's just not organized right
they Ambush it's merely an idea
highly organized movement nor is it
merely an idea it's a loser so it's odd
that we have not well where are they
because you know they show up everywhere
there's protests
but no they don't come on television no
but this is this is it is oh sorry go
ahead it is different than the proud
boys it's not as organized elected
officials haven't appeared with them we
all agree on that but Christopher Ray
said we're seeing people exploiting this
situation after George Floyd's murder to
pursue violence extremist agendas
anarchists like antifa and other
agitators again
there is no there is no person you can
point to and say oh that person
represents antifa every time they see
four black people they think of Santino
to be honest it's actually largely white
that's what we said there are people
online who go who are openly identify as
animals well they may and I'm going to
say I think oftentimes
things like antifa are things that are
thought up ideas that are thought up and
pushed and moved because for me you know
if antifa if we go with the name
anti-fascist it's anti-fashion so I
don't know who's doing what I do know
that if you had asked a number of people
of color about Tucker Carlson we could
have told everyone but yeah what he
really felt yeah and that this wasn't an
act right this was who he was